hello guys and welcome back to politics
where because of recent events I don't
really have that much to do in this
video I don't start on a new section of
the park but the Japanese section is
almost done the only thing that I still
have to do over here is finish this
little Plaza with its building then it's
pretty much finished so there are a
couple things that I wanted to do in
this video and why this feels bit like
an oddball to me first and foremost most
of this video is actually ended up being
going back to different parts of the
park and sort of refurbish them tweak
them a little bit because this is now
alpha-3 pretty sure this is actually the
first
alpha-3 video that i'm releasing and
there's lots of awesome new stuff to
play around with and while i'm not the
kind of person to actually show it off
there's definitely kinds of things that
I haven't placed in a park yet because I
couldn't or I didn't know about them yet
now I definitely want to get back to and
actually put in there so that's
something which I'll spend a lot of time
on which means that the time-lapse is
gonna be roughly 13 minutes a little bit
more which I didn't feel was quite
enough yet so I hopefully can make it up
a little bit with a real time section at
the end sort of giving us more overview
of it but I know that doesn't really do
it anyway so on I'll try to do my best
for the next third here it's actually
get a good start of the new area more
about which I'll talk about in the real
time section now to actually talk about
what I'm doing here I want to finish
this Plaza with a building and the
ferris wheel just to neatly wrap up the
Japanese area and actually make use of a
trick which somebody taught me on Steam
and for the life of me I can't remember
who it was so if you're watching this I
am so sorry I'll get back to this when I
actually find it again but steam doesn't
have any chat logs and I haven't been
able to actually find back who actually
said it but it's basically a small trick
which is quite easy to do which I'll do
later on in this video as well to get
some actual grunt shrubbery in in a
sense that you can't really do otherwise
basically the person told me on Steam
that if you place a tree and then
terraform afterwards you can just tell
form without moving the trees so
effectively if you tell reform to make a
small pit then place a tree inside of
that and raise the land up again to make
it flats you actually
a tree that's soaking into the ground
and you can actually make some bushes
and with like a slight sort of slope on
the terraforming you can actually kind
of define where at what height that tree
is gonna sit so you can do all sorts of
shrubbery things with that which you
probably do otherwise so that's actually
a very neat little trick which can be a
bit annoying to use but you can make a
lot of good use of it and definitely in
this Japanese area where I did want to
feature a bit of Japanese as gardening
around this big temple like building it
came in pretty handy so about the
building itself it is a very very simple
building just a sort of standard
Japanese temple building I'm not the
biggest most knowledgeable person about
this so I'll just address it as it is it
is basically a food court that pretends
to be a Japanese temple that's quite a
bit fancier than maybe it should have
been but it's just a food court
like many other food courts that you see
in Park takes apart leading into it a
few stalls inside and bit of services
benches little bins that kind of stuff
and it's all nicely hidden within a
building and yeah it's actually quite
simple that way a lot of it also kind of
comes down to what I've done in the rest
of the area so far it basically just
builds on everything I've built in all
the other buildings which I also have to
say this really feels like a very good
point to end the Japanese area from a
gameplay perspective as well because
this is kind of like that points where
you've already sort of done everything
you can do in the theme and new
buildings that really become so much
more like new buildings but they're more
like another one that you've already
made so in that sense this really felt
like a good way to end it all this
building doesn't really bring any any
new kind of scenery ideas it's just a
variation on the Japanese building so
far but it was fun to play around with
and make little food courts and actually
it's rested up a bit more like the
Japanese garden
the outside I'm not sure if I actually
talks about this before I probably have
but the idea behind these bushes is many
Japanese gardens are quite different
from European Gardens in that they feel
a lot more natural like Japanese gardens
often have topiaries and bushes in all
sorts of shapes as well much like
European gardens but while European
gardens are like a pair of very man-made
they've got also two very unnatural
shapes and positions and a lot of
symmetry going on things like that
Japanese gone and seemed a lot more
natural they kind of have a flowy thing
to it that's why I was really happy with
that trick to lower trees into the
ground because the bushes that you get
in the game are quite small but Japanese
gardens often have these very large
round flower bushes and this is at least
one step closer to kind of getting that
sort of idea now the rest of this video
is all about working on the rest of the
park and the first thing that I wanted
to do is connect the monorail because it
wasn't connected yet but one bigger
issue that I should talk about with the
benefit of hindsight is it still doesn't
have any other station and I really need
to add another station and this is quite
awkward but I have to admit that I
completely forgot about the fact that I
need to add stations to this thing and
well realistically I definitely want to
have a station in the Japanese area
we'll see how that's gonna go because
I'm not sure if there's really any space
left for another station but at the
moment I just wanted to connect the
monorail not leave it so empty anymore
and I'll figure out about this station
at some point in the future right now
it's just one big loop that doesn't
really do anything otherwise placing
that tree actually just quickly made me
realise that I was still in pause mode
which wasn't really great for placing
down trees and I think actually the
time-lapse looks a little bit more
interesting as well in on pulse mode so
um on post unposted there for a bit and
added that very small I think it's a
venom it no it's it's a little store
something I'm pretty sure in any case I
figured I could fill that space with a
small store which would be more fun than
just leaving it
or making it more forests which is quite
a bit boring and the next thing that I
wanted to do is work on the main streets
now the main street was built in a
version of alpha one development build
and didn't really have that much yet
this was like built right after this
stony path was put into the game so it's
quite old and since that time many new
objects have come out and I just wanted
to revisit this thing obviously I have
also gotten a few more tricks and gotten
a bit better at the game as well and I
just wanted to revisit the Main Street a
little bit it is at this point quite
iconic for the park though so I didn't
want to touch it too much but there were
just some areas that felt a bit too
empty and some things which could
definitely just be improved and given
some extra detail given their new
objects that we have one quite relevant
piece is the new cornerstone which is
supposed to be used for like an industry
or ask a theme I'm pretty sure but
actually came in quite handy with the
different themes in the park so far and
so far I've just been using door pieces
as cornerstones and this does work a
little bit better so I figured I would
go with some actual corner stone some of
the windows could have used some more
cornices iraq I mean what's the word
awnings that's it some of the windows
still could use some more awnings so I
added a few of those and there's lots of
planter's stuff all around it as well I
am pretty sure that at the time when I
built this or when I got back to this it
was possible to build planters but you
can yet erase them the game still saw
them as regular plants and you can raise
them much like fences and swai the Main
Street uses some parts to actually raise
fences and only has planters on the
ground level so I wanted to get back and
use some of the planters as window boxes
which seemed quite fitting figuring the
Alpine theme many Alpine buildings to
have that quirk of having window boxes
and in general just adding more foliage
to the very densely built places just
kind of makes them a bit more charming a
bit more blending into the natural
environments so I wanted to do that
quite a bit and one other thing heavily
inspired by shyguys alpine village in
water coaster tycoon 3 some of these
alpine chimneys which I thought would be
a little bit nicer than just the
standard chimneys in the game made out
of the big haunted house chimneys with a
very white scholar and using the new
industrial pipes to give the tops of
chimneys you can actually make some
pretty nice custom chimneys I think at
this point I have been able to use more
chimneys as any kind of object that is
not a chimney I'd use any kind of object
that is not a chimney to make chimneys
out of then vice versa which is quite
funny but it actually works out pretty
well so I figured I would do that for a
little bit and some of the rest over
here is a bit of foliage I'm not
entirely sure what I'm gonna do with
this area though I'll talk about the
theme a bit more in the future but the
way that it's gonna be laid out I have
no clue yet and that's why after placing
there was a couple of trees then I
pretty much moved on to some things that
I still wanted to do as well
one of which is adding a bit more detail
to this station here shape wise I was
always quite happy with the station but
it just doesn't have that much to look
at and I just wanted to add some
accurate detail to it some of the parts
just seemed very gritty very standard
not very interesting to look at so
wanted to add some extra detail to that
and this part over here didn't really
have as many pop elements as it could
have so I wanted to add quite a few of
those as well really if you sort of just
have a very empty area and you're not
really sure what to do with it I always
think it can work out quite well to just
add all sorts of planters and benches
and lights and little bins to it until
there is barely any space left it might
be a bit of an overkill at some points
but it's always better than having a
part that's completely empty especially
with a park that is already quite dense
as this one is quite busy as well I
figured I could have go for some extra
path elements here now especially the
planter pieces work quite well in that
regard you can just kind of plop them
down next to benches and next to lights
to make them come alive let's
more they don't really occupy too much
space and I would want to be careful
with where you place them like the
guests always kind of walk in the middle
of a tile so the size of the tile are
pretty much safe but if getting planters
anywhere too close to the middle of the
time or can be dangerous at some points
because you might get guests walking
through it but pretty much most if not
all of these should be more or less safe
and shouldn't have before go straight
through it now this restaurant is
building over here I'm pretty sure it
does have a restaurant inside didn't
have any kind of sign and while I can't
really add any letters to it I thought
it would be nice to add at least some
kind of small sign and the rest of this
is very similar to the Alpine area just
adding a bit more detail in some ways
that I couldn't before especially the
cornerstones came in quite handy over
here since many of the Mediterranean
buildings thought it would fit in quite
nicely with but yeah I didn't really
have access to any of those corner
stones up until this point and then
there's the very big mountain of
buildings which the log flume goes
through which I pretty much built and
after that didn't really look at again
which could still use a little bit more
detail to it not 100% what sure what all
of these details are supposed to be and
some of them are a bit overkill as well
perhaps but it's always interesting to
look at especially since I do figure
making a park in an isometric game like
this even if you would look at it 3d it
has a very minimalistic sort of
rollercoaster tycoon
style to it it is very different from
making a realistic theme park so I'm not
too worried about making all of these
extra details in here and now in the
middle of those buildings I just wanted
to quickly place a tree which might seem
a bit weird but I'd I wanted to get a
tree in there rather than just a simple
sort of backstage roof because I wanted
to avoid the backstage real theme park
roofs just to keep this well also more
appealing from the isometric perspective
that's why I quickly wanted to place
that in there anyway that's it for the
time lapse I'll give it over to my real
self that's amazing I wasn't able to
recreate this earlier but apparently by
placing trees in pulsed mode you can
actually cause trees around it to fall
over
so I place a tree over here and over
here and it suddenly did this it's
pretty cool to be able to recreate it
though I won't actually how long that
shockwave will go on but basically you
just go to normal mode and they should
yeah it's taking a while but there they
go
that's pretty cool though it might be a
bit better to wait until that glitch is
not on the game anymore also one thing
that I should say I've gotten quite a
few comments about this Q line over here
which didn't actually hook up before and
now that's hook it up so that's great I
love how much attention I can put to any
kind of detail around the park and yet
miss little things like that I really
need my viewers to look at stuff like
that but yeah just a very quick overview
of what we have at the moment we've got
the sue go in there so japanese area
over here which is more or less finished
right now I don't think I can actually
go into this area too much there should
be plenty of room - yeah expand into
another area over here
and this is pretty much japan right now
with its pagoda a nice little station
well i say little but it's pretty
sizable a pretty sizable station for the
inverted coaster which pretty much is
the big sort of drawing Rini of the
japanese part of the park and along the
side of that we have one very big
winding wide path with all sorts of
rides and restaurants and basically
everything that's important to this area
around it and that's the very basic
build up of this area there's some of
the smaller things which I've added
alongside pretty much every part of the
park some smaller details little fancy
spires and pointy bits on buildings
which are new in alpha 3 so actually no
they were new in alpha 2 but I never
added them which were new in alpha 2 but
I never added them so I wanted to add
them alongside many parts of the park
cornerstones are new in alpha-3 so many
of the sort of amateurish cornerstones
that I had on many buildings of the park
the way that I built them using door
pieces like that have been replaced with
regular cornerstones this stations also
got a bit more detail to it there's more
planters and all sorts of little
elements on many of the buildings in the
park and the main street has gotten a
bit more detail and shape to it to fit
in more with the rest of the park and
yeah that's basically everything now
next time I hope to head into this
section and it's probably going to be
the western theme since it just seems to
be the best fitting style and the style
that's most touble in this game even
though I still have to figure out how
exactly I'm gonna do it so um yeah I'll
try to figure out how I'm gonna do that
and leave you guys at that hope to see
you guys next time and thanks for
watching